wenn ich allein ist auf dem server bin
gehe ich in die farbenwelt eine
vorwarnung diese folge könnte anfang
oder am ende oder irgendwo in der mitte
oder halt immer zwischendrin sehr
verstörend wirken
wir sind nicht immer so trotzdem viel
spaß
hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen ab heute in einer folge haben
muss dem retten muss den retten haben
für heute einfach gedacht dass wir
wieder mal so ein paar
ich war hier noch nie drin übrigens nein
nein nein das ist wichtig für den
transport von gütern oder vista ich habe
bisher in meiner ganzen minecraft leben
karriere so zwei eisen abgebaut der
rapper schon mehr in seiner bude
drinstehen übertreibt
doch da gehts doch das geht man wenn man
rein läuft geht das lässt bei den abfall
so wie ich bin grundkraft und ich bin ab
rechts neben will jetzt bin ich
glücklich war die lage wirklich doch
jetzt eine junge nein
im vergleich jeder gesagt dorthin und
langem schwert weg die boot aus der hand
ich verlasse die bude ja ich glaube ich
würde hier weil ich nicht ausgeben
ich hab kein wasser ich hab meine
richtung laufen halt immer so ne ich
will ich weiß nicht was ich machen soll
wenn ich so minecraft leben aufnehmen
wenn ich alleine ist auf dem server bin
ich in die farbenwelt verfolgen wir
verfolgen ja kommt dass muskeln all dem
weiß nicht nur das war über das wo er
ein großes hingelaufen halt auch nicht
einladen fährt mit einem kürbis dass ich
nicht dass ich noch nie gesehen stell
dir vor das war einfach so ein pferd und
das wird einfach von seinem kürbis
geritten
ok wie krass war das denn dann nehme ich
dir was ich sagen wollte ist ich hab
halt ich weiß ja nie was ich zu machen
habe ich irgendwo hoch dass wolken den
wasserfall und erschoss mit dem a4 bogen
um diesen monat das können natürlich
jederzeit passieren liegt nicht daran
ihm kriegs von mir weil du ja gerade
noch so frisch dabei ist tricks von mir
fünf stück b6 stück for free bergheimer
geschäfte hier nun die drogen bilder des
künstlers blaue wenn wir jetzt einfach
nicht auf 73 werde schnell die drogen
gedealt aller das blaue wagen freundlich
weiß man nie was ich in meinem leben
machen soll weil das einzige was jetzt
zum beispiel auch wieder gemacht habe
ist nicht ab sondern von fährt geholt
sondern einfach auf mein grundstück und
deswegen wollte ich mir einfach eine
leitung bastelt in der folge hey du
lässt es sein
du lässt dass sein einsatz spricht dass
so keine perspektive für dich du willst
springt das hoch alter da war es nämlich
hier
da ist es wieder das erfährt da das
gerät nicht hinterher ich reiten tun
hatten die reiter ist bestimmt nicht mit
meinem pferd da ja
der bau der iss nicht denn der 23
doch jetzt geht es so mit solchen
blödmännern geben wir uns nicht ab
und jetzt muss ich das dann irgendwie
das ist aber du hast doch geschenkt nein
der stadt wobei mir um und stand bei dir
weil du hättest und mein pferd ich habe
irgendwie das gefährt der folge direkt
also nicht dass ich jetzt noch
irgendjemand aufregt kommentare sorry
und freunde ich wusste wirklich nicht
gehört ich dachte ich dass du das
irgendwie hatte ich dachte aber schnell
schnell speedrun papa spielt war frank
okay was für geben uns zu starten aber
hat eine zahnbürste noch service auf
youtube zum beispiel sportarten oder
ähnliches onanieren land willst du
unbedingt mal reisen kanada
wärst du blind oder taub und ist die
schwere frage nächste frage vielleicht
bei irgendwann könntest du dir
vorstellen mit mit matt oder mit jet und
mit allen zusammen zu ziehen
hattest du schon eine freundin ja ok
oder war die frage ob man sich zur zeit
mit freundin schon mal um zu bestätigen
dass du nicht mit mir unglaublich schwul
bist ja schon nach staffel als freundin
hatte ich schon mal ein fan an der uni
angesprochen
tatsächlich noch nicht wie glaubst du
wirklich mal geschrieben noch entwickeln
so ein goldener abschluss wird luca
bereit bereit so die antwort ja ich
stelle mich dafür auf dem berg und dann
sage ich
der kolibri erschwert irgendwo
hinstellen serviert rein also kollege
wenn du dein pferd so steht beim bbz
nummer zehn begnügen
bitteschön revue es ist ein profi ist er
wieder alle sein pferd oder wird es kurz
ausgerutscht ausgerutscht und
ausdruckstiefe color black square
hinterlegt
du bist etwas besseres einfallen hat mit
der türen weggeblieben hinzustellen ist
ein bisschen ist es üblich den returns
und das wollen oder das möchte
vielleicht doch nicht jeder und so wird
auch wenn fans statt geld zum dass ich
entweder wir machen das machen muss man
schon wie wir sind die türen sekte hat
jetzt bald welt bald der tat sitzung
aufsichtsrats im internet alles gut wird
ein wert an alle mitglieder der türen
sekte 2 eingeladen bei kekse und kuchen
wird dann über die zukunft diskutiert ja
kommt der film abläuft
wo müssen ich steh auf dem berg auf dem
höheren ehre der möhren berg wo geld ist
also möglich wenn ein schild findest du
wirst voll krass ihr alter mit dieser
dieser regeneration peng scheiße die
hier ja das ist richtig krass auch wie
schnell man damit ist echt cool so
wartet der der möhren weg ist auf meinem
grundstück das heißt dachte er eine tür
insekten in seitentür insekten sekte war
weil man setzt das nicht mehr wenn man
in der sekte ist an 66 man alles was
schön hin gesagt komm durch die tür und
erfahre die wahrheit kommt durch die tür
und der fahrer die wahrheit durch die
türen erfahre die wahrheit kam durch die
tür der barbie war ein durch die türe
weil die valovis karlsruhe sie muss
kaufen die wenig warum sie sind sonne
b freunde
a